this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host you
jump in we'll talk about your
life and your money open phones a triple
eight eight two five five two two five
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author and author of
the brand new book that is on pre-sale
right now from paycheck to purpose the
clear path
to doing what you love he's my co-host
today he does the ken coleman show on 75
plus radio stations answering your
questions about your career about your
job
about finding and living in your passion
because you spend too much time doing
something you hate
so all those kinds of questions along
with the normal stuff we take here on
the ramsay show the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five brad's in washington dc hey
brad how are you
i'm doing well yourself better than i
deserve how can i help excellent
well i'm proud to say that i'm a baby
step sevener whoa good for you
thank you sir i'm only 40. yeah i'm
still young but
people probably think i'm old just a
mere
we don't we don't for the record brad
we're older than you we think you're
very young
nice that's what i'm talking about
all right so my question is regarding my
emergency fund that i've held for a few
years
i updated annually based on how much
money we spend so i make sure i'm
keeping six months in our emergency fund
however i also have savings of you know
the next two years for 2022 and 2023 of
our
retirement account of contribution to
the roth
our hazard insurance for our home our
real estate property tax
my 529 plan for my child
hsa um what else you have that saved up
for two years
for the next two years why
because i don't know what else to do
it's a safety net it's a beyond a safety
net
well
you know it's good when january 1st
comes like
one of my proudest moments is to be able
to make those contributions so i can
one fell through a year off well okay
right one i'll swoop so i do the
transfers boom
all right so emergency fund i was kind
of thinking like it it's burning a hole
in my brain just sitting in the you know
internet savings you have two years of
this other crap sitting in a savings
account but this is burning a hole in
your brain
yeah
so that's weird the reason being
i'm sorry that's okay but can can i use
in
my thought process is should i use this
additional savings for all those various
things kind of as my quasi emergency
fund do i need an emergency fund in
addition to that stuff
okay um
it's good to have some money
it gives you peace okay and knowing and
it gives you a thrill to hit the submit
button on january i get that
um
none of those accounts i mean you have
money sitting there for those accounts
it could be used for any type of
emergency if something superseded in
your life right i mean something bigger
here correct and so
uh you need to pay for a relative's
funeral uh suddenly uh you want to do
that you can do that out of some any of
those funds it doesn't matter you know
your car transmission goes out you know
all of those things that's what
emergency funds are for
the unexpected
events
um
do you see how it's inconsistent to be
worried about the emergency fund sitting
there doing nothing while you have all
this other money sitting there doing
nothing also
mm-hmm okay that's what i was laughing
that's what i was supposed to do
yeah yeah you're a wee bit conservative
yeah but it's okay i have a feeling
you're baby step seven you're 40 you're
probably a millionaire are pretty close
you will be soon if not
and so none of the the loss of income on
all of these funds is not a problem
right it gives you peace
and that's what it's for so i do not
keep uh that much
i i do not label cash two years in
advance uh for anything
um i have piles of cash that are in
retained earnings in the business i have
an emergency fund um
and i have stuff that is coming up this
year that i've earmarked and set aside
but i don't have two years out on
anything
but it does not give me a thrill to dump
it all and hit the submit button in
january either and it gives you a thrill
so if you want to do it you've got the
money that's all fine but if i were
going to cut back anything it would not
be your emergency fund it would be that
that over saving or early saving for
those other things what are you hearing
i'm hearing a hyper super achiever
who's going
i'm in baby steps he's a baby steps
millionaire and he's he's so far ahead
he's got
all those accounts set aside so he can
do it this is a guy who loves to achieve
and he's a really meticulous planner and
i think that's all wonderful i would
tell him to relax a little bit you don't
get to baby step seven by accident relax
a little bit and you're not the the six
month emergency fund's not burning a
hole in anything that's what it's there
for yeah go invest in something else go
give some of that money and see life
changing yeah so i set some money aside
for random crazy outrageous generosity
yeah just go buy somebody a car you're
very impressive you don't need to do
anything very cool you've done an
amazing job yeah an amazing job but yeah
you're you're you're an overachieving
super nerd and that's
that's what i am so i kind of relate to
i understand how you're doing this am i
it didn't bother my emotions because i'm
kind of right there with you dude but uh
but i also don't actually physically
tactically do that either yeah so hey
good question thank you for joining us
jane's in chicago hi jane welcome to the
ramsay show
hi jay thanks for having me how are you
today better than i deserve how can i
help
good hey i have a question about my
parents
they are both retired have sold their
home to move closer to my husband and
our children
went over budget on the purchase of
their home they drained the retirement
account to be able to purchase a home in
this market despite our concerns with
that
my question is how do we help them
going forward my dad has a retirement
from his state job a pension
but my mother has nothing and they have
no long-term care insurance
well
i think there's two things you can do
one is if to the extent that they will
accept your coaching i would coach them
on their budget and on purchasing some
long-term care insurance
75 percent of the ladies outlive their
husbands
so papa goes into the nursing home
cracks and scrambles what little nest
egg there is
going to the nursing home dies and mom
is left with nothing and that's what
you're outlining here that's what's
that's what the future looks like so we
need to set the you know we need to
fix that with long-term care insurance
if they will accept your coaching you
can step in and help them with their
budget but they didn't accept your
coaching on the house purchase
um the second thing you can do is you
just go do what you're supposed to do
and become wealthy because only the
strong can help the weak
you don't need a mutual fund that's
nicknamed mom and dad you just need a
pile of money and when you've got wealth
if you want to help a relative then
you're in a position
to do that
this is the ramsay
[Music]
so
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less for just 30 a
month get unlimited talk text and six
gigs of data with no contract the
average family saves over 70 a month by
switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
825-5225 he's the host of the new book
from paycheck to purpose
the clear path to doing work you love
if you pre-order it now
at ramseysolutions.com you will get 100
to 150 worth of extra goodies
and uh there's all kinds of things
happening around this book
um
you need to you need to get a hold of it
and
look at the uh uh the assessment as well
which has been very popular ken yeah the
get clear career assessment dave is
about a 15-minute digital assessment and
we're going to give you a great report
on what you do best your top talents the
kind of work you love we call that
passion you'll get your report on that
and then mission the results that you
want to put out into the workplace
through your work talent passion mission
report you also get a purpose statement
with that
that is very detailed and really becomes
your north star as you look towards any
professional growth and then also
professional possibilities for those who
are looking to figure out what is it
that i'm supposed to do with my life so
it's a great resource that if you get
that and the book it's an unbelievable
bundle for 30 bucks so that's a really
good deal it's a really good deal from
paycheck to purpose and the get clear
assessment holleyramseysolutions.com our
question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings free
samples free shipping and new promos all
the time use the promo code ramsey to
get the best deal today's question comes
from sean in missouri i'm currently in
baby step two and i will be completely
debt free next year i have a career but
i'm not sure if it's my calling is it a
bad idea while i'm in baby step two to
pay for a one-time coaching session with
a career counselor to get some career
goals and get some guidance on how to
reach those goals i can budget in the
expense and pay for it with cash on hand
so i wouldn't incur additional debt
that's not a bad idea
that is a very inexpensive in the grand
scheme of things if you're in control of
that budget and you cash flow for one
session that's not going to cost you too
much i would do my homework though and
make sure that it's a reputable coach
but i'd like to save you the money on
the coaching session and uh for thirty
dollars you can get that get clear
career assessment at ramseysolutions.com
and uh get your results and then call
the ken coleman show give me five
minutes and then we can decide on a
career coach uh and i think even then
that is a good decision to get some
clarity from somebody else and so that
we begin to say all right now i can
begin to see the mountaintop and i can
figure out how to climb up the
mountaintop so you can definitely cash
flow that good idea
oz guinness years ago did a uh
a talk a book called the calling yes
and um man i guess that was probably 25
years ago i read that book something
like that
but um
i've noticed in my life that uh
the first thing i started doing was
earning money to eat yes
and uh so get the wolf away from the
door pay the bills that kind of stuff
took a job yes the second thing i did
was i moved from that into a career yes
with meaning
and um and and i'm talking about the
stuff i do today it start it didn't it
didn't start all altruistic i didn't
start with
a clear understanding that this was the
calling on my life
now i can look back 30 years later and
say of working in the same thing and say
this was a call yep it's god's call on
my life and i'm sure of that and those
of you that have
benefited by the things we do around
here are sure of that and so uh but it
but when i started
uh you know and i get in front of the
microphone the first time write the
first book um
i was still in career mode at that point
i was beyond job i was i was trying to
do something with meaning and so forth
but i was not
i would not have been prepared
truthfully yes
to say that's a calling i had to realize
that a little bit later yeah and you
know what i'm glad you actually brought
this up now i'm not sure when you're 21
and you're in college you know what your
calling is no
but i would say if we redefine calling
for just a moment and say calling
is to be
who you were created to be now once you
find out the answer to that you can make
a great career out of that and that's
what we teach but calling if we really
look at it we say what what is calling
that's how we at ramsey solutions look
at work when we say works on a
four-letter word folks we're trying to
challenge you to say you were created to
work created to contribute
and so calling is realizing that there's
something that i was created to do
because i've got talent it turns out
there's things i love to do and turns
out there's results that really
fire my heart up so calling is actually
being who you're supposed to be career
multiple ways to fulfill calling
and i suppose the the phrase evolved
from
uh
from people of faith or
a pastor would say god called me
to preach
and um
you know our good friend rabbi lapin a
jewish orthodox rabbi
says that the word worship and the word
work
are very similar words in hebrew that
did that in a very real sense that when
you're working you're workshipping
that's exactly what it is and that's why
we have
uh worship service on the weekend and
customer service
on monday
you know and so that's uh there's a lot
of overlap there and so calling is
saying
it's a throwback whether you whether
you're a person of faith or not you're
accidentally throwing back to people of
faith and saying okay god's calling me
his calling on my life is this which is
what you're saying is what you're
designed to do that's it that's it so
you are you we are all called to
contribute if i'm going to say that i
mean at the end of the day that's what
god wants for us is to just be us
because we all got something unique to
contribute
phone number here is triple eight eight
two five five two two five pamela is
with us in greensboro north carolina hi
pamela how are you
i'm well how are you doing better than i
deserve what's up
all right so um my fiance and i are
brand new listeners we are in baby step
two i'm gonna try to keep this brief
um basically i had a marriage end after
i purchased a house a few years ago uh
we split about three months after the
purchase he has no legal
anything to do with the house and
basically i
went into a chapter 13 bankruptcy to try
to save it i was living in the house at
the time i got a job that is about an
hour away
in greensboro so we moved um miami
beyonce moved outside of greensboro we
are currently renting a trailer
and renting out the property which is a
you know fairly nice property with an
in-ground pool that we pay expenses for
um we do have a current tenant there
but with the property value increasing
right now i'm wondering if we should
just
sell the house and keep a little bit of
coffee
yeah okay
that made that easy
well here's the thing the house has
nothing to do with your future it has
everything to do with your past
exactly and really it's a problem it's
not a blessing
okay and that's what i've been feeling
it's been a lot of stress well you have
a pool
yes so i know it's a problem i know it's
a problem
i hate my pool otherwise known as money
pits it's a money pit
so i'm kidding but you said you brought
the pool up which tells me you got an
[ __ ] and it's a you know a couple
hours away and you're having to screw
these tenants and screw this pool and
and it's all got to do with the past and
not the future dump that thing it's a
problem it's not a blessing
all right that makes sense yeah
yeah that's kind of what i was leaning
toward i think i just needed validation
because everyone i talked to like no you
should keep it well everybody's broken
down don't listen to everybody
yeah you you know you knew in your heart
what you needed to do you just wanted
somebody say it out loud
i think so yeah you're smart enough to
make this decision yeah get after it
kiddo get after it and then you use that
money to clean up whatever mess is left
over from the chapter 13 dismiss the 13
voluntarily step out of it and then you
can start to rebuild your life from
there you guys get your marriage done
and then you start talking about buying
something on your own after you're
debt-free and have an emergency fund
hold on i'm going to send you a wedding
gift it's called the total money
makeover it's helped 8 million people
get out of debt appreciate you being a
new listener
this is what we do here on your show in
my show we say what people already know
they're supposed to do and we get paid
for it yeah that's exactly right
you know double blessing on that is
that's not just the financial win but
the emotional win i love that you
pointed that out that represents a bad
season
get rid of it yeah there's some stuff
you just don't want to keep around it's
like oh
yeah that's true yeah cleaning out my
house right now
getting ready to move and i'm finding
some stuff like that i'm like oh what's
that still doing here
it's a problem
this is the ramsey shaft
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
lobby of ramsey solutions on the debt
free stage michael and angela are with
us hey guys how are you good how are you
better than i deserve welcome where do
you guys live
we live in uh just north of dayton ohio
about an hour okay great welcome to
nashville and you're here to do a
debt-free scream how much did you pay
off
123 000. excellent and how long did that
take you
about four years and five months all
right
and your household income had ranged
during that time
about 89 000 at beginning and then we
ended at 110. excellent what do y'all do
for a living
i'm a police officer
and i work in business administration
very good awesome guys what kind of debt
was the one hundred and twenty three
thousand
it was a car in our house all right why
look at the weird people
house is paid for everything you're done
you did it yeah i love that guys how old
are you two i'm 39 i'm 36 and you're not
even 40 years old what's the house worth
about 216 000
boom yep it is all yours yes 100 years
yes you ever think you'd have a paid for
house
30 years from the time we signed the
documents but yeah yeah absolutely when
i'm 90. yeah yeah
maybe when i get there yeah oh my gosh
and then but not before you're 40. no
wow very impressive very cool
so uh tell us the story what happened
well
i'm the free spirit he loves to save so
it was kind of just one of those things
and you know i don't want to talk about
money
one day i was at work and i had a
co-worker come up to me and say
oh hey you know so-and-so's over there
listening dave ramsey and i was like
well who's dave ramsey and she's like oh
he's a money guy he thinks on a podcast
so i instantly turned on the podcast and
went home the evening and i was like hey
do you know who dave ramsey is and he
was like no i don't think so so
i listened a few more days and i was
like i think we can do this i think we
can do this he's like i took a guy on a
radio for you to figure that out i love
it oh i was saying the same things you
say all the time just yeah didn't listen
yeah common sense and then some guy on
the radio makes her a genius yeah i said
sorry there's a little jealousy there at
first i'm sure i was like
on the
it's all about the tone it's all about
the tone okay
yeah dave could get away with that on
the air but if he tries that he's on the
couch yeah there we go that's right
well it's not my wife dude that's okay
right that's helpful too yeah
if i try that at home i might be on the
go oh sure oh my gosh way to go you guys
so that gets you started four years and
five months ago on the podcast and you
come home and and he said of course no
kidding let's do this okay and then what
did you guys do
well basically made a budget
um stuck to it
every time i saw too many amazon boxes
showing up you know i knew something was
going off the rails so you know
brought it up that way but we have an
amazon box detector on the front part we
do yeah we do yeah so ring doorbell
notifies me while i'm at work and you
broke the budget yeah so i made the
budget stuck to it and we just we set a
goal for
set paid it off at 10 years the house
mortgage and we did it at nine
so we were we beat our goal because
it just worked out that way yeah so wow
way to go you beat it a bunch four years
and five months right yeah wow that's
pretty impressive
very cool
now now uh outside the two of you who
were your biggest cheerleaders
i'd say our parents parents and my
sister
um outside that everybody thought we
were off a rocker so it's fine
of course what are you guys doing okay
so uh what did you do that besides just
telling people this maybe that made
people think you were off your rocker
i'm curious what are some intense
gazelle things maybe that you did
i mean i think we just said no a lot to
going out new cars you know we kind of
just
stuck with hey we got a bigger goal here
um at least for me that's how i felt
yeah i've always lived that way yeah
he's fine yeah he's like this is i'm
like he's like again again
yeah what did you
what what
what is the account for uh the big uh
jump and pay i mean that's a nice little
jump right there what happened well
actually right before this i took a pay
cut to move to a different job to spend
more time with the family and then i got
raised this to be back where it was that
before so it worked out great yeah so he
got promoted and then i had changed jobs
a couple times during the process yeah
okay wow and thank you for your service
yeah what you do yeah congratulations
y'all well done how's it feel to have no
payments
amazing
i'm still kind of in shock you know
you're waiting for every month to the
you know the payment to come out or you
know and now it's like oh my gosh it's
ours so here it is
just like that yeah i love it way to go
so when people ask how you paid off your
house before you're 40.
there's people watching right now
listening right now
how do you do that what what is the key
to getting out of debt
contentment was my big thing rachel's
book you know
live your life not theirs that is so
true i feel like social media is such a
huge issue you know you see everybody
doing stuff new cars
blessed
so
it's very that was my struggle he's
perfectly fine living at scorched earth
and i'm like i can't do this so
getting in your head of realizing you
know there's a bigger why and something
you know change your family tree so
you gotta do it for
the kids and yourself
i feel like the kids were a good
motivation for us to give them a better
future absolutely set them up yeah
absolutely well well done
very well played very proud of you you
got to feel accomplished yeah absolutely
it feels great you're going to be baby
steps millionaires in no time yeah
i mean you're right on your way we got a
copy of the legacy journey for you
that's definitely the next chapter in
your story you've changed your legacy
and a copy of the total money makeover
for you to give to a friend like that
one told you to listen to podcasts that
time same kind of thing spread the love
out there and pay it forward so very
very good stuff and you brought the
kiddos with you what are their names and
ages uh we have brianna who's eight and
clarissa who's six all right very fun
very fun
all right it is brianna and clarissa
angela and michael and just north of
dayton ohio 123 000 paid off house and
everything
four years and five months making 89 to
110 and they're not even 40. shut up
count it down let's hear a debt-free
screen
three two one
we're
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i debt-free it absolutely fabulous very
very well done guys
well if you get a house you want to get
it paid for this housing market right
now is super super hot
and uh your house could be worth a lot
more today than it was when you bought
it what that means is if you've not
updated your homeowner's insurance you
probably don't have adequate coverage
old days the policies automatically
updated and followed the value
nowadays they don't do that
and so you could have a 200 000 policy
on a 400 000 house it burns and you are
screwed
no you don't do that you want to keep up
to date and if your home values gone up
or even if it's been a little while
since you've shopped it uh homeowners
insurance is kind of it's a good time to
check it right now you might save some
money you will probably save some money
talk to one of our endorsed local
providers they are ramsey trusted and
they will shop a gazillion different
companies and get you the best possible
buy
on your homeowners insurance you'll
likely save some serious money doesn't
cost anything to go shopping
just go shopping and give it a shot see
what you get you might save 700 bucks a
year you might save 500 bucks a year you
know you never know text the word home
to 33 789 and talk with a trusted
insurance pro about finding the right
coverage for you text home
to 33789
and uh ken coleman ramsey personality is
my co-host today here on the air uh he
is the host of the ken coleman show on
75 radio stations across america and on
top of that they are played on youtube
on podcast and anywhere great radio is
heard and great voice oh it's everywhere
so it's all about you getting into the
career you love you getting into a plan
that that makes sense to you and where
your passion lines up the new book is
called from paycheck to purpose the
clear path to doing work you love
it's on pre-sale now which means for 20
bucks you can get the book and a whole
bunch of other goodies at
ramseysolutions.com
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
and coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today william is in riverside
california hi william welcome to the
ramsey show
hey dave hey ken what's going on ken
finishing up the proximity principle and
looking forward to your new book so
congrats on that thank you um
yeah okay so here's my situation um i'm
active duty navy and about to be moving
at least three times in 2022 my wife is
about to graduate from her master's
program in occupational therapy and
she's going to be getting her
credentials to practice in the first
half of the new year we are on baby step
two on our second to last debt which
should be paid in the next two months
and that would just leave us with eighty
thousand dollars in student loan debt
we're looking forward to making our
shovel bigger with my wife being able to
work in the field but we've been talking
a lot about when we will start having
kids and we're concerned about balancing
the dead snowball and starting our
family uh so i'd love to see my bias and
comfort in this situation
uh we don't we don't decide about kids
and marriages based on debt
when it's time to have babies you have
babies you'll work it out
you'll work it out you've got plenty of
room they're not that expensive they uh
they don't eat that much
uh all this crap the kids will i mean if
you have 17 kids it'll break you that's
different but if you're gonna have a
baby you're gonna be just fine
you're gonna be just fine and the same
thing with marriage the only thing we
tell folks about marriage is you need to
be on the same page
that you're heading in the right
direction to gather but i don't tell
people not to marry someone with that
and i don't tell people to not have
babies because they got that yeah as a
matter of fact quite the opposite it's a
good reason to have babies what's the
timeline look like
forget that for just a moment to
start trying to have babies with your
wife moving into a new career have you
talked about that
a little bit you know we kind of go back
and forth because she does have a little
bit of shame and you know the fact that
most of the student loans that is hers
and i've you know
that's not a big deal um but
i guess somewhere between when we're
moving next year we'd like to at least
start we're going to be coming off of
birth control soon and um we're just
kind of looking forward to maybe mid
but yes i think it's a shame that's
getting us
i know yeah there's no shame yeah
no babies are god's gift and babies are
the best thing ever happened to me yeah
and she's she's going to pay that off
she's going to make very good money as
an occupational therapist you guys are
on the path you know how to pay this off
you're going to get there have the
babies and you're going to get through
the baby steps all right let's go ahead
and say
she's probably an occupational therapist
for a while yeah because you got to
clean this mess up that's exactly so
it's not like she's gonna be a
stay-at-home mom
uh you don't have the you don't have the
budget for that that's but it's not that
you can't have kids uh for sure so you
do what you want to do it sounds like
you already are
i miss the part where i like i'm gonna
say no when they're going to go back on
birth control that's that's really
awkward as crud
but uh no i'm definitely not going there
so um i i can't even believe i said that
out loud but anyway that's what he said
it's what he said so it's a little warm
in the studio all of a sudden for me i
don't know about anybody else
no they'll get it i mean you know look
she's she can be a working mom and crush
this thing and that's beautiful
bo is with us in miami hey bo how are
you
i'm good dave i'm like so freaked out
that i'm on air right now
okay it's okay we've never lost a
patient yeah he sounds pretty good
this is crazy okay uh
yeah i'm bo i'm in miami i currently
make
35 000 i work for a non-profit that i
really really love
and they just called me and asked me if
i'd be willing to continue working for
them but in a different state
and i'm torn because this is really what
i want to do and i like the work but
it doesn't line up with the amount of
money i make doesn't line up with paying
off my debt in two years
so
i don't know what to like i'm torn about
whether i should go with the career and
like really let like that be what drives
me or whether i should stick to the
numbers and then work it out after that
i really want to be that free actually
as possible but i was like started every
4 30 maybe not too good how old are you
25 okay and you're going to pay off the
debt in two years if you stay in the
current situation making 35 000 no no no
what i make right now 35 is not going to
get me that in two years i've already
paid off 23 000
and i have 59 000 to go okay well fan
first of all fantastic so how much money
do you calculate that you would need to
make
to be able to pay off the debt in two
years or even less what's that number
that's like
70 000. that's almost 70 thousand
dollars and i already do like full-time
work with the non-profit so
right what are you and you're making
you're making 35 000 with this
non-profit so another 35 000 really like
37 sorry 37. okay great well here's the
deal if if i just want to give you an
alternate
uh narrative for a second if you were to
go get a 70 000 job and in this economy
you can right now you probably could if
you're qualified or you could get there
you could make that money you could also
get a side hustle uh a good you know a
second job and really bust it and you
could get there and make that kind of
money
but if you weren't doing this work that
you love
you wouldn't be able to do that for very
long you could do it long enough to pay
off that debt and then get back into the
nonprofit world that is a viable option
uh but you have to be okay with that or
you can stay there and work for this
this organization that you really really
love doing the work that you know you're
supposed to do and then you just bust it
and you work hard you really just cut
cut cut cut cut in every waking hour uh
at 25 years of age that you're not doing
that work you love you're doing work you
have to do and i think you can get there
so i think you've got a couple options
there how about a third option oh here
we go or we find something that pays 70
or 100 000 a year that you love doing
that is a viable option as well it's not
just the nonprofit why do you have to
make less to love what you're doing i
don't understand this concept
i don't think that you should make more
doing what you love
yeah
and part of me thinks like maybe that
what is it about your work that you love
well i love that i get to share the
gospel and i love that i get to like
really work with people like better help
communities like respond to the needs
and of people around them that's very
cool so do i yeah
yeah and i make a lot more than 35 000.
yeah and i share the gospel every day
yeah i just i've never been offered like
a job while i have a job and so
it's kind of hard for me to think about
i'm not i'm not i'm not challenging the
job i'm just saying that i think the
things that you are doing could be done
a lot of different the things that jazz
you could be done a lot of different
ways and it doesn't even necessarily
have to be under the heading of
non-profit that's correct
nonprofit's not in the bible
non-profit is an irs designation
it doesn't make it holy or righteous
because it's non-profit it just means
they're broke yeah
so what we're saying is you're not
you're not destined to 35 000 you can
make more doing work that is ministry
related uh and you can make more uh and
i think you will 25 you're still very
young but but the reality is you've got
some serious options here i wouldn't say
no to this the general question the
first question was should i take this
job i've been offered an opportunity but
it doesn't make as much as i would like
it to make to pay off the debt as fast
as i want to pay it off right well she's
already in the 37. she's talking about
moving to another state and a similar
thing right less money even yet well
cost of living and so um no i don't
think you can make it make the move to
the other state so
um
here's the thing what i'm trying to
shake up here and i'm being snarky to do
it which is my normal method um
is the the narrative the idea that a you
have to make less to do what you love
that's just not true it should be the
other way and b
that in order for you to be able to
share the gospel and minister in the
community that it has to be in a
non-profit setting or it has to be in a
setting where you don't get paid
anything
and none of that is true
those are not true narratives
and so you can uh be a compassionate
kind giving generous person working in a
compassionate giving kind generous
organization uh that is christian based
and sharing the gospel and
there's a lot of places that'll pay more
than 35 000 doing that yeah and i want
to point out the the the last piece of
that though that if you know let's take
a teacher in our the largest millionaire
study ever done by ramsey solutions
third largest group of net worth
millionaires teachers median salary the
median in the united states is 60 000.
when you find that work you love uh you
can still pay off debt and you can still
be
a millionaire but you're gonna have to
live differently and cut your expenses
and you have to take a second job from
time to time to pay off that debt so you
know it's not about the size of the
salary it's what's my lifestyle to do
the work that i love depending on the
profession
beautiful thing about the generation of
people in their 20s
i think we call it the peace corps
generation because they have a heart to
serve the community
even if they have different belief
systems different faiths there's a heart
to serve it's beautiful
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where that is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place
of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us america
open phones triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five ken
coleman ramsey personality is my co-host
today number one best-selling author and
host of the brand new book that we have
launched pre-sale on from paycheck to
purpose the clear path to doing work you
love again triple eight eight two five
five two two five joseph's in kansas
city hey joseph what's up
oh not a whole lot thank you for taking
my call sure how can i help i i have a
career question with a
life insurance side question
the question first of all is how do i
transition my long landscape business
from a one-man operation where i do all
the work to one where i
make the sales and supervise the jobs
that i sell
and i can give you as much background as
you'd like yeah well i mean if we
simplify it you've got to train people
to do what you do to the level
that you do it and it may not be exactly
that but pretty darn close to where
there's trust transferred from two p
from two entities trust from you to them
to where you actually go do the things
that you need to do for the business
because you have trained them and you've
seen them do the work and they're doing
it and then trust from your customers
that they're not seeing you out you know
in their yard or around doing the
landscaping but they see other people
and they see results at the same level
you've been doing them i mean that that
really is that simple and that means
you're going to have to train but then
you're going to have to let somebody go
and do it and show them and be patient
and find people that really enjoy
working outside people that enjoy doing
the kind of work you enjoy doing joseph
when i've heard the first people i hired
um 25 years ago
i was stupid
i was so dumb i thought if you hired
people they would like work and stuff
and i've had to learn how to lead and
how to delegate and work on my business
not just
in my business as my friend michael
gerber said in the book e-myth
and um so the the
the thing that i learned about what
you're doing which is delegation
from a leadership standpoint you're
going to delegate some of this work
you're going to trust these people with
your brand with your reputation with
your customers
where you made all the customers happy
the chances of them pissing them off
you're trusting all of that right
the only way you can do that
intelligently is exactly what ken just
outlined and that is the way you can
delegate is you have to trust the people
you're delegating to you have to trust
their competence
or can they do the work
and their integrity
and you cannot delegate and you should
not delegate to someone
until you've trained them sufficiently
to trust
their competence
and their integrity
and it takes a little time now it
doesn't take a lot of time to delegate
get me a cup of coffee
that's a pretty basic level right i need
a cup of coffee i'm in the middle of
something and somebody else goes and
gets that that's a delegated task do
they come back with a coffee we can
measure the results uh are they
competent do they have integrity did
they lie three times along the way i
mean people can screw even that up right
and so um uh you know but but now you're
saying we've gotta we have to complete
lawn lawn care and that's probably going
to be with you still riding the tractor
at first
and you're riding with the crews you're
now heading up a crew
and then you find your lead guy in the
crew that can lead the guys to do the
work at the level you expect and then
you can step back and do that again
but when you delegate to someone just
because you hired them and gave them a
title
and you and they have not proven
competency and integrity that makes you
stupid and i was stupid i did that stuff
and i screwed up some stuff man i had to
pissed off customers because i thought
if i hired a guy to do that or a gal to
do that they just would go do it that's
how dumb i was and you it's exhilarating
to say you can't expect what you don't
inspect yeah that's so good you know and
i would say this too that that uh when
you're training those people those
clients are going to see you out there
training that's going to help create a
checkpoint list this is what i expect i
showed you how to do it but this is what
i want done and then i would stay the
face of this so you're going to sell for
new clients but i also want you to stay
as the face of customer service for the
new clients so you're not out there
cutting lawns and doing all the stuff
but maybe once a month you show up and
go hey how's everything going and i
think if you do that you're still
focusing on the right thing so you're
still checking the job for quality yeah
make sure you know
i've got a buddy that owns i think
they're running six trucks now
uh in the lawn care world and he's got
gps on everything he knows where all of
them are at all times yeah so if they're
parked at the gas station for two and a
half hours
um when they're supposed to be cutting
he knows what's going on right
and so you've got you've got ways to
check and to follow what's going on you
can check the quality of the work and
you have to constantly do that the rest
of your life but the more that they've
worked for you and the more they've
proven themselves the more rope you can
give them the more freedom you can give
them because you trust heavier their
competence and their integrity hold on
we'll send you a copy of the book entre
leadership we outlined some of that in
that book
and uh it'll help help you get there
and uh of course the way you do that is
you've got to get enough accounts
going and it sounds like you're right
there that you need the help and you
stay the first thing you do is you staff
your own crew
and then you then you put a leader on
that crew and then you staff another
crew that's exactly right so it's as
simple as all right i'm going to do most
of this i'm going to get a sharp young
man who wants to work hard i'm going to
teach him i'm going to get them started
i'm gonna run over three streets over
and i'm gonna get the next one started
you can get a couple part-timers you
know you just ease into this because
your reputation is as dave said once you
hire somebody and you put them on
somebody's lawn that's your reputation
it's not just their reputation so uh one
thing i want to tell you to anticipate
is you got you know i hear this a lot at
entre leadership events i'm blessed to
speak at those for ramsey solutions we
hear this a lot i can't find anybody
it'll do it well that's not true
you've got to ask yourself why do i like
working outside what what about this
kind of business got me into it find
kids like that because they are you know
some people just don't want to be around
a bunch of other people right they want
to do that kind of work we hired a guy a
long time ago and customer care this is
a great story he came to work and his
third day here he just stood up threw
off the headset and went running out to
his car and left
and when we called him we're like dude
where did you go
we went through all this hiring process
and everything and he goes i just i just
realized i can't work inside
that's right
so well i mean when you were
interviewing we like told you it was in
a building and stuff right yeah yeah
yeah i just can't work inside i just
can't work inside
so on one hand we appreciate his honesty
he didn't handle it the best way well
you've been nice to know up front yeah
it's been nice that we do our call
center inside yeah yeah well first of
all there's a great clue if you love
working outside with tools and being
outside don't take a call center job
it's not for you
yeah oh that's that was great i mean he
truly we thought he we thought a family
emergency or something happened oh sure
stood up slugging the hell sat down on
the desk and went running out to his car
just disappeared it had enough yeah just
after three days two and a half days
[Music]
this is a hard place to work we're
inside and stuff yeah this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at ziprecruiter
have made the whole job search way
easier ziprecruiter is rated the number
one job site in the us by g2 and it's
free so how does it work first go to
ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's
ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
we were laughing
going into the break about the young men
running out of the building i can't work
inside well at ramsey solutions
we're hiring
for inside jobs i want to point out
there before dave they're all in the
side they're all indoors
oh
so here's the deal we are trying to
shake up this culture
and we're doing a pretty good job of it
we're trying to disrupt the way people
think about careers
with the ken coleman show most people
hate their jobs and ken's on a mission
to stop that
uh most people retire broke i'm on a
mission to stop that most people wallow
in debt i'm on a mission to stop that i
want to make the credit card the
cigarette of the financial world where
nobody wants to do it anymore it's not
cool anymore
because it is that it's killing people
but uh it's a problem we want to disrupt
if you want to be part of something
that's pretty serious disruption
oh we'd love to have you if you want to
join the crusade
you know about half of our thousand
people are technology people because a
lot of our products are digital products
obviously so we've got software
engineers with experts
expertise in ruby on rails java c-sharp
front-end technologies ux designers seo
people content folks
data engineers data analysts
and we need all of them we're hiring
about 300 people this year to add to our
thousand
and if you want to check out the
available jobs tech and otherwise
uh it's a high-tech environment uh which
means i absolutely do not understand
what most of the people who work for me
do no but that's um that's part of it
but um i do understand uh enough about
their competence and their integrity to
delegate to them yes and to their
leaders who do know what they're doing
so that's good
so to find out all the available jobs
text work to 33 789 text work
233789
right here at
ramseysolutions.com you can jump on
there and find out as well tom is with
us in lima ohio hey tom welcome to the
ramsay show
hey dave and ken it is an absolute honor
to speak with both you you too sir how
can we help
okay so i'll just give you a breakdown
of where i'm at um and then i'll get to
the question um i'm 19 years old getting
married next year
um i have a hundred and eighteen
thousand dollar net worth and here to
break that down for you i got 52 000 in
non-retirement 11 000 in roth ira
25 000 in savings 28 thousand dollars in
a paid for truck two thousand dollars in
a paid for car and i have zero debt of
any sort wow how did you pull all that
off at 19.
um i mean i guess i would contribute
most of that to my grandfather he
introduced me to his show about two
years ago
and he's just helped me out between
him and you guys just a lot of
inspiration there and a lot of working
hard and savings what do you do for a
living
i'm a welder okay what kind of money are
you making
i'm making about 55 000 a year at 19
years old good for you when'd you start
welding
um i started welding i'm in a factory
whenever i was 16 through a school
program i'm working second shift after i
got off school
and then as soon as i got out of high
school i went full time fantastic
there's a great story dave of the trades
you're a stud yeah i love it how can we
help you sir
so my question here today is my
grandfather's farm
he is 72 years old
and he's getting closer to
finally admitting that he's ready to
retire and slow down a little bit so
he wants to sell me the farm i'm about
the last one in the family that's
interests in it
the farmer's worth about 1.1 million
dollars and he's asking five hundred
thousand for it
um and then there's probably roughly a
hundred thousand dollars worth of
equipment that i would have to purchase
off of him over time he wants fifty
thousand dollars down
and he wants to do a uh land
contract i think is what it's called
at the minimum required interest rate of
1.2 percent over 15 years
so i guess my question there is
i want to make sure that this is a good
financial decision for me if this isn't
going to be too much for me to take on
um with getting married next year and
and wanting to start a family after that
the farm brings in about 30 000 a year
so after that the actual
mortgage payment so to say on it
would only put me at about 500 to a
thousand dollars a month out of my own
pocket
and i would plan on tackling that way
faster and hopefully having it paid off
in about five to ten years
do you want to be in the farm business
yes
not welding this is what you want to do
well i want to own the farm like i still
want to keep my day job of welding and
then it's about a hundred acre farm so
it's
i mean grandpa's always just done it as
a hobby he always drove truck over the
road full time
and then farm too so that's kind of what
i'm wanting to do is just
have this as a away life i guess
um so i guess the question would be is
you know
i guess based off these numbers that i
don't know it's just a lot to bite off i
want to make sure it's not going to put
me in a in a bad predicament
where
until i get married next year how much
is your wife going to work outside the
home
yes she's going to bring in about 45 000
so that'd be
100 000
you're going to live on the farm
yes it has a house on it
yep okay
probably about uh 17 or 1800 square foot
brick oriental okay
and what's the rest of the family say
about you getting this at 50 discount
i mean they're all on page for it so
over the last year we've had a lot of
family meetings where grandpa sat down
all the kids
offered it to all of his kids first none
of them really
spoke up as interested um but you're
getting a 1.2 value for 500
yes
okay
all right yeah and he offered it to all
of his kids nobody wanted it
nope none i mean none of them really
have i'm taking it i got to make one
adjustment
there's no way under the sun i'm doing a
land contract
okay they're dangerous let me explain
what a land contract is it's called a
contract for deed
the deed is not in your name
you have a contract that gives you the
right to the deed when you pay the
property off if before you pay the
property off the owner of the property
were to get sued
and have a lien placed on the property
they would not be able to transfer the
deed to you even if they wanted to your
grandpa falls asleep at the wheel and
hits somebody head on and they sue him
for 500 million dollars for a wrongful
death you lost your farm and it wasn't
your fault
because it was never in your name don't
do that
okay
or your grandpa dies and all of a sudden
his children's memory of the fact that
they didn't want this farm goes sideways
and the property's not in your name it's
a contract now with an estate that is
now in dispute because your uncle lost
his freaking mind when he found out you
bought it for 500 instead of 1.2
yeah
and this has never happened in any
family right
say it again i said this has never
happened in any family
yeah i'm sure the property goes into
your name
or you don't do the deal and it's called
a mortgage then it's not a land contract
okay it's an owner finance mortgage on
the terms that you outline and then no
one can take it from you as long as you
abide by the terms of the mortgage and
if you don't then you could get
foreclosed on by the estate which will
be the owner of the mortgage
your grandpa's estate when he passes is
who you will owe the money to
okay
and then you go out there and take all
the ot you can get and bust your butt
and pay this thing off
that's a plan because i it scares the
crud out of me but there's so much
that's right here that i'll overlook a
couple things that are wrong i will not
overlook that land contract i would beg
and plead with you not to do a land
contract
okay i think i outlined all the risks
clearly didn't i
yeah i do believe so
[Laughter]
tom you're a strong young man yeah
that's a powerful place to be at 19
years old
uh you're biting off a really big chew
here yeah i'm a little nervous about it
yeah it's a lot of chew it's a lot of
hobby here's the thing that's what he's
saying listen to me it's in his name
that's true
four years from now you're right it's a
nice asset you can sell it for 1.5 if
you decide you're over there you're
right i love it if it don't if it don't
work out it's going to work out that's
true it's good real estate
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage athena
is with us hi athena how are you hi dave
how you doing better than i deserve
where do you live i now live in fort
worth texas all right well welcome to
nashville and all the way up here to do
a debt-free scream how much have you
paid off 93 317 and 60 cents love it and
how long did this take 33 months to the
day whoo you were kicking it what was
your range of income during that time i
made uh 70 change jobs took a pay cut
and ended up making up to 78. okay
that'll work good for you what kind of
debt was the 93 one car and student
loans wow okay so what happened uh three
years ago that set you on fire um well i
wasn't really on fire for the first year
and a half made my first job out of
college kind of messed around with my
money had a little fun with it was like
i worked really hard for this i deserve
to have a little fun with my money
um
moved to orlando ended up pulling your
book back out that i purchased while i
was on an internship in 2017
read it took some notes in it put it
away what made you pull it out it was on
top i don't know
it ended up being a god thing i packed
up my everything moved to orlando and
when i opened the box it was on top ah
it's all shuffle the deck thing pretty
much um read through it again took some
notes put it away and then
2020 happened
and i said well i've been saving up for
all of these things these fun things
that aren't going to happen
so what do i do now
pulled the book out again
read through it and said well
we're gonna kill it we're done scorched
earth okay
so
the uh a little bit of wandering along
the book keeps popping up
and uh what month did you
go to complete
uh defcon 10 or whatever i mean where
you just went crazy what what was that
in the middle of covid
yeah uh they were like a year ago yeah
they sent us home in march i've been
working
um from home
turned on your radio show it ended at
five o'clock and i knew i could get off
at five o'clock i started listening to
it the book popped back up and i said
well beginning of april
and then a year later so the last 14
months of the 33 have been game on
absolutely i paid off double in the last
13 months than i paid off the first yeah
so you didn't do anything you just paid
off debt yeah yeah you pretty much
finally got there okay
wow very cool
how old are you i'm 26. oh wow fantastic
good for you what'd you get your degree
and i'm curious a mechanical engineering
with a minor in economics and did you go
into that right out of school i did yes
are you still in engineering i am yes
yes you have a very bright future too
and we're having a good time with it
yeah good that's awesome very cool what
was the hardest thing you did because
you said you didn't do anything but you
also made some tough sacrifices to be
able to do that in 14 months what'd you
do what was tough
the hardest thing
was to realize that
this wasn't my money i was making it i
deserved it i was having fun with it but
it had already been spent wow like i had
already made that choice that's good
step there
that's good and that that hit me like a
ton of bricks about
june last year i was like well
what was the weirdest thing you did that
your friends all gave you the eye roll
for um the weirdest thing i did was
actually do
um
[Music]
the ramsay plus i went and i took these
courses and i was telling a couple of
friends of mine hey i'm you know i've
run out of things to do you can only
watch so much tv and so i started taking
a financial wellness course and they
looked at me and they're like you need a
financial wellness course
uh don't you make too much money to have
problems i was like no we all have
different issues
so um did that took all the money i was
saving for a family vacation we were
planning to take overseas said well
they're not going to let us into their
country anyway right now and threw it at
my debt wow
wow and now you're free absolutely
you're glad you did it absolutely i
actually will be finishing up my
six-month emergency fund at the end of
the month and it's
diff everything is different yeah how's
it feel
um
shock it feels like shock you don't
really know what you're doing until you
start putting your money away to make
the next payment and then get the letter
that says congratulations you know
here's the check for the overpayment you
made of one cent
cost us 16 to generate this check pretty
much
yeah
wow good for you what do you tell people
the key to getting out of debt now that
you've had the book pop up and you went
through financial peace university at
ramsey plus you've done it all what's
the key to getting out of that
um the key that i've been telling people
and you know the few people that have
asked me is
um we want to to do what you did and
it's like you're not going to do what i
did your journey is going to be
different from my journey which was
different from all of these people that
i listened to their debt-free screams on
the radio
you know i did it on one income you know
you just got married you have two
incomes or you know
it's
going to look different but that doesn't
make it wrong
okay that's good
yeah good insight very well done good
job
very proud of you who are your biggest
cheerleaders i have to say my biggest
cheerleaders where my sister two
wonderful mentors alex and josh and my
wonderful boyfriend here drew
who looked at me and said
you're
kind of crazy but
we're here for you like what do you want
to do what's going to make you
successful we want to see you do this
i love it that's great that's really
good now that's an interesting thing
dave
so when you said they look to you like
you're kind of crazy they're like i'm
not sure you need to you're a mechanical
engineer you don't need to be this
gazelle intense they didn't use those
words but that's essentially the emotion
am i understanding you're right yes and
yet they still said but we support you
and i think that's important you know
people who they may not see it but
they're going to at least support you
yeah that's important because not
everybody's going to see this yeah
you've got to have community this is
very counter cultural yeah way to go
good for you proud of you excellent job
hero yeah took control of your life you
got a bright bright future ahead of you
you'll be able to do anything you want
to do after you've done this
you climbed the mountain well done well
done we got a copy of the legacy journey
for you that's the next chapter in your
story because you have changed your
whole legacy and a copy of the total
money makeover you can give it to
someone it'll just keep appearing in
their life until they finally do it
it's like a bad penny it just keeps
showing up i love it america's greatest
largest coaster for coffee tables
everywhere i love it she just opened it
up to your faces right there total money
might go over there it is again it just
pops up it's just
just a reoccurring theme so well done
athena we love it fort worth texas 93
000 paid off in 33 months making 70-78
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three two one i'm dead free
[Applause]
[Music]
that is absolutely fabulous
now what's key here
is uh and sometimes people miss this
stuff because you some of you watch the
news too much and you you need to turn
it off it's a bunch of crap amen but um
all you hear about millennials and
20-somethings is how they're all
uh participation trophy
avocado toast eating
no
ambition living their mother's basement
useless
and you know we know at ramsey that
that's just not true because of two
things one is we see them on our
debt-free stages every day
we have these 20-somethings that show up
they're just amazing that kid 19 years
old a few minutes ago calling in here
absolute amazing young people mature way
beyond some of you that have your lips
stuck out you're 55 years old somebody
smacked that scowl off your face
and um they're just unbelievable yeah
and we know they're amazing and we've
also got a building full of them and we
don't hire people at ramsey that aren't
rock stars and that don't care deeply
and that aren't excellent at their jobs
and they have a tremendous work ethic
and they're the easiest to interview
because there's only two kinds of
millennials awesome and sucks
[Laughter]
and so they and they'll just tell you i
don't really want to work much and i
want to know what your benefits package
is well you suck your next interview
you know i don't you know we want
somebody here that's gonna work yeah and
we want somebody like her that's fired
up and wired up man whoever hired her
they got a jewel oh
rock star this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
luke is with us luke is in
kansas city hi luke what's up
hey guys good afternoon thanks for
taking my call sure how can i help
so i travel through the midwest selling
building materials in four states
missouri kansas iowa nebraska
i drive my own vehicle and the company
gives me a vehicle reimbursement program
as you can imagine i drive about a lot
of miles about 40 000 a year and
certainly have racked up the miles on my
personal vehicle
my question is
should i
buy a second vehicle exclusive to
work travel only
and separate the two since they do give
me
so much money a month
well the the misnomer is that the money
that you get for vehicle reimbursement
all has to be spent necessarily on
vehicles
that's not true it's just part of your
income
and then you just have this unusually
large expense associated with your job
which is uh gas maintenance and
replacement of a vehicle you destroy the
value of every two years
and so that's correct yeah you've got a
budget for that if you want to get a
it's not a bad idea to get a second car
but the reasoning for that is not that
they give you so much money because they
really don't give you so much money
after we factor in the loss in value on
whatever you're driving because whatever
you drive you destroy it value-wise
that's right
and so um yeah what i always tell road
warriors is that it's a business expense
and the goal with business expenses to
do the minimum
uh expense
thereby maximizing profits
and so the less we spend on car the more
money you have
and how do we how do we minimize the
damage done to your finances with you
being on the road all the time and so
my formula is you buy the least vehicle
least expensive vehicle that will get
the job done
in quotes now let me describe to you
what i think get the job done is in this
situation
if i spend
40 000 miles a year in a car it's gonna
have a it's going to be a decent car
that rides well i'm not doing that in a
in a you know a freaking dodge neon
okay because you'll be in the
chiropractor uh you got to have
something that's a decent decent ride
because you're in the car all the time
okay so that's part of get the job done
the second part is it has to obviously
be reliable
but you don't take a sixty thousand
dollar vehicle and go destroy it
you take a twenty thousand dollar or
fifteen thousand dollar vehicle and go
destroy it
and then you figure out what you know
what that does and
uh um and every two years or every three
years however you want to do it i mean
120 000 miles 80 000 miles you got to
roll that thing over and do it again but
you've lost every bit of the value
during the time you drove it uh and
that's just that's just part of your
reality and that's okay it's like
it's like you own a heat and air company
and you got four trucks on the in your
uh fleet going out and calling on houses
it's part of your cost of doing business
so but you want to limit that you don't
go buy a
you know 150 000 service truck if you're
in the heat and air business and if
you're smart anyway
and so that that's how i would do it and
now okay so now we got a 12 000 or 15
000
whatever okay you call it whatever you
wanna call it i don't care it's got
reasonable gas mileage it's uh
reasonable comfort and is reliable now
do we spend some more money on something
that sits in the driveway most the time
that is my quote real car
unquote that i don't plan on destroying
and if you want to do that either way
you're going to pay cash for both
and both of them are going to go down in
value but obviously the one on the road
is going to go down the most and the
fastest and that's how i look at being a
road warrior in that anything we've got
around here we do the same thing you're
amateurizing
the expense
uh you know another example in our world
is we buy we spend a lot of money on
computers around here
a thousand people they've all got a
computer
and uh you know what that computer's
worth in two years
nothing oh boy
wow nothing
and dave is okay with that it doesn't
bother me
there's no problem
it's a doorstop after two years yeah
it's like
something else comes out and the same
with this stuff you know i got what two
million bucks in a stinking studio you
know and all the wires and the
electronics and the spaceship it looks
like you're in there running nasa or
something and
you know it's probably got a five year
shelf life
wow and uh so you just gotta look at
that and go okay
stinking stuff is gonna deteriorate the
electronics don't deteriorate but the
the stuff that they plug into on the
other end becomes obsolete
might i make a suggestion dave to see if
you like it
i'm opening myself up here okay all
right so we're talking cash we gave this
man advice it's got to be cash
uh maybe he gets a uh maybe he gets a
car that runs but it's an older car a
classic car and the value doesn't go
down he's on the road monday through
friday and when he's driving around on
the weekends it's is he i'm just saying
that he's he's in his car gea maybe
like yours yeah yeah that car is going
up in value each year it's nice and it
runs not bad i'm just saying that my
1960 corvette's actually going to go up
in value but there's very few things
that go up in value that have motors and
wheels yeah very few things and they
don't go up much no it's not like you're
gonna make no this isn't like real
estate and it's not got you know
neither one of those cars have the
creature comforts of the modern vehicle
yeah that's true there is no but it's
not a horrible idea is what i'm asking
not about i don't mind i'm saying hey if
you take that you could have a little
cool get around on the weekend just
something find a tool around then a
weekend ride yeah you know but it's not
your quote daily drive no yeah that's
not a bad idea but again you don't want
to spend 100 grand on that oh no you
can't have a lemon and this is you got
to be smart about this purchase yeah in
terms of i mean the purchase price
doesn't have to be that it's no no no
it's a it's a driver so it's not a
museum piece so it's a it's interesting
world but yeah
the thing is you're gonna lose the money
on it yeah so alex is with us in austin
texas hey alex welcome to the ramsay
show
i pushed the wrong button didn't i
alex is in austin texas hey alex how are
you
hey thanks for having me i thought i was
the one that messed up no that would be
me you would think after 30 years of
radio i could push the right freaking
button
what's up
okay so i am 25 i have
18
18.7
000 left in a student loan
and i recently took a new job well in in
may and my previous company i had a
bunch of rsu's some stock
that i had and that's about sixteen
thousand
um i've read you know numerous things i
don't know if they've been from from
iran's or elsewhere that were
kind of advising against selling stocks
to pay off debt and tax implications and
all that so i kind of just love your
take on that because
i could see uh sixteen thousand dollars
and probably two more paychecks and that
that's going so yeah well you did not
read from ramsey the anything that we
wrote that said don't sell stocks to pay
off debt because we always say sell
stocks and pay off debt
so it was quite the opposite and our
issue is a restricted stock unit is it
still restricted
no these are all uh
mine now yeah so you're fully vested and
you can turn them off and it's
it's 16 000 worth and it makes you
almost debt free
yeah i'll do that by like
in the next two hours
okay immediately don't hesitate
do it be done with it
because here's the thing
let's pretend you had no debt
would you go borrow on a student loan to
buy restricted stock units
no of course not effectively that's what
your balance sheet says
okay you understand what i'm saying
yeah yeah absolutely so as if you kept
them it's as if you bought them again
using student loan money to do it
because you should have sold them and
paid off your student loans so all those
other articles you read were wrong
yeah that's right
yeah
by the way restricted stock units folks
are in initial public offerings this is
a brand new startup company and uh which
makes this particular company by
definition volatile yeah
and so uh you what you do is you get out
while the getting is good because
everything doesn't turn into apple on
facebook i'm just saying
three words cash out baby
that's it i'm done and then you're debt
free with another couple checks that's
huge that's fun and he there is another
and mid-20s and so you know it turns out
the stock
benefit was a blessing fantastic
blessing but we're going to use it
wisely
that puts us hour the ramsey show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it
stay tuned
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
theramsi show.com thanks for listening
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
dean is with us in pullman washington hi
dean how are you
feeling good how are you better than i
deserve what's up
well first i just want to say it's an
honor to talk to you um
i have a question
regarding a piece of scripture and then
wealth
and you probably definitely know it but
it's in mark 10 and he talks about
that it's easier for a camel to enter to
the eye of the needle than ever expand
to
enter the kingdom of god
my question is
what is your advice on how to take that
verse into account when establishing a
life and investing and essentially
building wealth
um
yeah what's your advice on that
well i appreciate your question i'm
going to send you a copy of the book the
legacy journey and i unpacked the rich
young ruler at quite length there but
i'll give you a radio version of
that story
because it's something that comes up a
lot these days
the concept being obviously a camel
cannot go through the eye of a needle
which means if you just take that exact
scripture exactly the way you read it
um then rich people are not going to
heaven
right right right well this is a bit
problematic uh from a practical
standpoint for two reasons one
reason is this if you make 39 000 a year
which is uh about 40 percent of the uh
or about i'm sorry about 60 of the
average household income in america you
are in the top 1 of income earners in
the entire world
yeah so if you live in north america and
you make 39 000 a year
if you take that scripture the way you
presented it
most people listening to this right now
are going to hell
well that's a little absurd when you
think about it
okay number one
uh so we kind of have to then we have to
pan back and go okay so what's wrong
with
the equation that i was using to look at
that what's wrong with this well
uh number one in the in the first
century following christ there was a
group of heretics called the gnostics
and the gnostics believed that and
there's still gnosticism
in the world today the gnostics believe
that anything of um
of substance anything of material was
evil and only the spiritual was holy
uh so things like fill the you know
filthy money that kind of thing came up
then and anything that anything had to
do with wealth anything that had to do
with owning a shirt
anything that is physical is by
definition evil even they thought their
own bodies were evil
uh where our scripture in evangelical
christianity believes that
that god you know is blessing us and
loves us and created good things for us
and in living in abundance now
the big deal with this is the gnostics
were heretics because they believed that
you could not go to heaven if you had
material goods much like we were just
discussing
now why is that why is that heretical
why does that make you a heretic if you
believe that
because those of us that are followers
of jesus believe that the blood of jesus
at the cross jesus sacrifice
when you believe when you believe on
that
that you're going to heaven whether you
were a murderer
before whether you were a prostitute
before
or even a rich person
before yeah
that the bully but if the blood of
heaven is good enough to get a
prostitute or a
a murderer into heaven and it's not good
enough to get a rich person into heaven
that is heresy
follow me
yeah because you're breaking down the
work that was done at the cross now
we're having a very biblical christian
discussion here but it's a very biblical
christian question and so it's the only
way to address it now
let's go back to that particular story
and pan out just a little bit because
you can take a single line of scripture
and completely create a toxic movement
over it if you don't take it in context
and so pan back a little bit let's go
back to the whole story number one
where did this occur
it occurred in jerusalem
jerusalem was the home of the spiritual
elite the pharisees and the sadducees
and if you were a rich young ruler you
were by definition
part of the religious elite
if you were in jerusalem now if this had
occurred in galilee he might have been a
merchant
but the because the merchants would have
been the wealth holders there but since
it occurred in jerusalem we know by
definition from historical fact
that he was a part of the religious
elite which jesus by the way had very
little use for if you remember
and so he walks up and says good teacher
what have i got to do to enter heaven
and the good teacher says you have to
keep the law he said i've done this
since my youth which of course is
impossible no one keeps the law of pause
completely but and so that was an
arrogant but statement
yeah okay
but jesus plays along and says okay now
that you've done that let's prove it
sell all that you have and give it to
the poor and he goes away with his head
hung low because by the way the wealth
that he had gotten he did not earn the
wealth that he had gotten had been given
to him because of his status in the
religious community
and he went away with his head hung low
because he was a person of great wealth
jesus turned to the crowd and said it's
harder for a
camel to get harder for a rich man to
get into heaven that is a camel to get
through the eye of a needle right and
that's where it is now here's where the
magic happens not magic here's where the
answer happens
you keep reading
keep reading
and the disciples then are amazed
they were amazed that rich people can't
get to heaven
and jesus turns and says
no one does
no one gets to the father
except through the son
so this was not a teaching on wealth as
a prohibitor to heaven this is a
teaching on grace that the only way
to him
to the father is through the son and
that's what that's what that's what
bible believers believe but then what
happens is people either a
they have an extra grind they're jealous
they have problems or socialists they're
whatever they are and they want to get
in and figure out that that somehow
christianity is inconsistent or hit are
full of hypocrites and they pull one
line of scripture
out of the story out of historical
context and out of the context of what
jesus was actually talking about the
reason the story is recorded is because
of that final line where jesus looks at
him and says one way yeah to the father
through the son yeah through him
and even even the rich people yeah
so that's the answer to your question
dean so
then it becomes okay who what are we
called to do as believers
we are called to manage
not to own
we're called to be kind and generous
we're called to do good with the money
that we take care of first step is take
care of your own household first are you
worse than unbeliever
scripture and then you work your way
through and you're supposed to manage
things for the good of the kingdom
if you are a believer
and that's what you're called to do
and so
last time i checked poor people aren't
feeding hungry kids
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at eight eight
two five
five
two two five
thanks for joining us we're glad you're
here
melissa is with us in seattle hi melissa
welcome to the ramsay show
thank you very much
hey what's up um
i had a question on what we should do
first um so we have everything paid off
besides my car which we owe about ten
thousand on which we should have paid
off within the next six months
and then my student loan which is
massive oh it's massive to me
and um so i'm a stay-at-home mom and my
husband's an electrician and so he works
for the union where even though he
personally has an experience they do
come in these periods where sometimes
they don't have work
for periods of time
so my question with that is should we
save after we pay off the car should we
save towards that 10 000 in case
something like that happens
or should i just knock out the student
loan debt
[Music]
what's your degree in
health information management
how many kids have you got
four
got a house full
what ages
1 to 13.
wow whoa
you are a busy lady
okay
what does he make
all together
met with
the va benefits that he also has we get
about 90 000 net 90
yes okay and how much is your massive
student loan
80
80.
okay
all right with a ten thousand dollar car
debt that means you need ninety thousand
making ninety thousand to be debt free
with four kids and we have a son who's
uh in going to private school two which
we were kind of cornered into because of
the washington state laws that haven't
passed recently
i'm not aware of what you're talking
about
um um
basically we did not we were kind of
cornered into putting him in private
school
because
we felt that
the public school district has become
very unhealthy teaching kids they should
not be teaching
and my son was being bullied as well at
school
because he's a christian hmm
okay
and how much does how much does private
school cost
under a little bit under eight thousand
okay
all right so if we said uh 30 000 a year
that'd be pretty aggressive in your
situation in debt reduction you'd be
debt-free in three years
okay the more unstable your husband's
job is the more you would push pause on
all of this and pile up cash
but i don't think it's that unstable i
think it's just unpredictable
yes and the maltese hasn't worked since
you started a couple of years ago was
two weeks
but then there in the history of the
union there was guys who didn't work
like in 2008 where they didn't work for
a year
yeah in which case you'd go get another
job yeah melissa i'm curious about this
too
if you guys sat down and discussed union
versus not union electrician
opportunities for him even in the state
of washington
um his union there he will not make what
he makes where he um where he is at i
mean the they make over 60 an hour free
insurance
our union the employers pay the
insurance great pension
there's no one that's going to touch
what he makes okay all right
has he actually shopped it or is that
just what the union told him
no that um so right now he's an
apprentice so he's getting a percentage
of that
but once he is licensed in two years he
will be making that and that is what
they make for everybody
and
yet we get
great insurance that's completely
employer paid
he's not gonna
and they're one of the best in
washington yeah how open is he to doing
uh side work as well whether it be
electrician work or any other kind of
handiwork because he's got more talents
than just electrician
yes and actually we used to own our own
construction business but i know he's
been trying to work a lot of saturdays
as much as he can good
and he is okay doing side work you can't
do it with being an electrician because
it's against the law in washington okay
how long has he been uh how long has he
been out of work what's the longest he
has been out of work
two weeks
and how long ago was that
last november okay
all right
and you can't eat on a thousand dollars
in two weeks
yes you can
okay so i'm gonna say i'm gonna i'm
gonna stick with the baby steps and i'm
gonna put you on a scorched earth budget
and he's gonna pick up all the extra he
can work you got a thousand dollars in
the bank in case he's off for two weeks
or in case some other little thing comes
up two weeks is not gonna kill you and
um you're not going to be out of food
everything's going to be okay
and um
if you see a long layoff coming he needs
to change jobs
because because your family can't afford
for him to have a long layoff
and then in the midst of that you guys
start really beating the snot out of
this debt and i want you debt free in
three years a hundred percent debt free
in three years that's that's the
schedule that's 2500 bucks a month for
three years
and you can do this but i'm telling you
you got your hands full with four kids
you got a lot of stuff coming at you
right now a lot of different issues that
you outlined in this call
and uh so
there's a certain amount of grown-up
stress with what you're dealing with and
i think you can do it though i really
think you can do it and it's what i
would do if i were in your shoes
because i think the best life for you
three years from today is to do what i
just said versus something else
and i mean you can have a pile of cash
sitting there if you want
uh it's not what we teach
and the only way i would teach a
polycash sitting there is if you have a
a
high probability that you're getting
ready to lose your job in which case you
need to change directions
on the
union versus non-union direction
uh because i can promise you that
there's a there's a
housing boom in seattle
and uh you can get a job as an
electrician
and um you're pretty much feeding me the
union line back
yeah when we're asking you about this
yeah good insurance good insurance good
insurance 60 an hour you can't make
anywhere else only he doesn't make 60 an
hour and he doesn't average that if he
gets laid off for six months so um i'm
not i'm not anti-union but you just
can't you know you gotta you gotta
assess the entire
opportunity here compared to being
non-union and then decide which one i'm
okay if he wants to stay union but you
can't you can't have it both ways you
can't go oh it's completely unstable i'm
freaked out but it's the best job in the
world right and let's be very clear a
qualified electrician that is in a
non-union situation can eat all he wants
to eat it is an all you can eat buffet
right now out there as far as work goes
so i would i don't know that you can't
make more than 60 an hour if i was
trying to get out of debt and i was an
electrician
i mean you can make up some ground right
now and that's not going anywhere
absolutely
absolutely brandon is in uh detroit hi
brandon how are you
i am well how are you guys better than i
deserve what's up
all right so i am a full-time nurse and
i started a business called photos and
what this is is i go into restaurants
take professional pictures of their menu
items post them to my website
foodphotos.com
and give them qr codes so their
customers have direct access to these
pictures
now i am having a very hard time
getting my information in the hands of
restaurant owners
why and
i've tried multiple ways one
going in and trying to speak to the
owner the person at the front door
shoots me away second approach go in eat
their food take pictures of it
talk to the owner or a manager and show
them what i do and show them how i can
make their food look amazing
and they say okay we'll take your
information and i never hear from them
again
i am told that it'll cost
between five and ten thousand dollars
for a consultant oh bullcrap
hold on a minute we'll talk to you after
this break that's cray cray
[Music]
me
[Music]
still on baby step number one how'd you
guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're talking with brandon in detroit
he's got a side hustle where he's taking
pictures of restaurant food putting a qr
code for the restaurant customer at the
table to be able to look and see a
picture of the food when they get ready
to do their order having trouble getting
restaurant owners to buy in
brandon do you he had a ten thousand
dollar offer for some consultant which
is bs um to do advertising for him
meaning that the guy made one sale him
um
the so brandon do you have any customers
at all
i do i have three customers okay uh what
what price point medium high end low end
right now uh i know how covet impacted
the world especially the restaurant
industry i am an instagrammer with a few
thousand no no
i said how
expensive is the food at the three that
you have
middle high low okay i see
okay it is
low to medium
okay
so those guys
know other guys
that are their competitors and friends
and will make a phone call for you if
you ask them to
ken has a book called the proximity
principle
and there's more that happens with a
relationship hands off than cold call
walking in the door
cold call walking in the door you're
gonna get thrown out by every angry
angry 21 year old hostess in the world
you're gonna get booted by the maitre d
every time but if you can get
a couple of these guys to call a couple
of the other guys
and that'll open up everything for you
hold on we're going to have kelly give
you a copy of the proximity principle i
wish i had time to completely unpack and
do a full business plan for you i think
your idea is cool uh but we are on a
schedule around here we have trains to
catch and people to take care of so
sorry about that on the la in the lobby
of ramsey solution on the debt free
stage matt and sammy are with us hey
guys how are you
how are you so here to do a debt free
screen where do you live green bay
wisconsin love it love it welcome to
nashville how much have you paid off we
have paid off 56 000 in 10 months good
for you and your range of income during
that time range of income was
75 000 to 109 000.
excellent okay good what do you guys do
for a living we're restaurant uh
managers actually funny
good to see you yeah yeah um so um i'm
the general manager of a buffet chain
restaurant actually and she's the
assistant general manager of the same
one we do oversee
a couple other restaurants as well and
then we had some side gigs of
health coach um we decided you know we
need to do something about our weight
especially you know being in the
restaurant industry it's so easy to eat
all the food all the time um so we were
like let's just you know jump in let's
join a program and lose some weight so
we did that and then we decided health
coach as well
which was great for us because it was
extra income yeah
and then we also did doordash we would
do that together frequently wow
what kind of debt was the 56 000
it was a
college degree and then two car loans
all right so what was the wake up call
10 months ago that made you decide hey
we got to do this
well a lot of it was i mean there was we
had a credit card and every month it was
2 000 and and it was like where's where
is this going you know what is it um
so we're just like we got to figure
something out so i put the credit card
down started envelopes and within
envelopes i was doing
i saved 11 000 in five months and i'm
like holy cow
so done with the credit card
we just started doing cash for
everything and it was crazy to see how
much money we could save up so quick and
that's really what opened my eyes a lot
yeah and then also um when uh when i
graduated college um student loans came
due and i was paying 900 a month and
that just made me sick to my stomach
yeah yeah i guess so
it was wow ouch yeah so then you
connected with us how
um i listened to a radio show in the
morning and they they always talk to oh
dave ramsey this you know you gotta you
know save up all your money and you know
use it on your debt and then save it for
this and i was like they talk about this
guy kind of a lot maybe i should look
into him so i was like let's just look
into him you know search your podcast
and i didn't turn it off um you know it
was on all day i went to bed listening
to it i woke up and listened to it i
listened to it as much as i could during
covet you know with the restaurant we
were closed for dining
so i was in the kitchen i would listen
to it in the kitchen i would try to get
other staff to be like hey check this
out you know so it's just crazy to see
what what can be done you know when you
when you put down your credit card and
really just use cash i mean you knocked
this in the head in 10 months that's
that's that's 5600 bucks a month
making 75-100 that's rocking it yep and
four years four years ago we actually
had a hundred and one thousand so we
paid off total 101 000. wow
wow how's it feel to be free
so good you know it's it's still pretty
fresh but it's it's just great you know
i wake up super early now and it's like
8 am i wake up i get up out of bed
before she's out of bed and i'm like hey
it's it's payday i get to you know just
pay off that loan or you know now it's
like i get to put this much into our
savings you know it's just exciting to
see what we can do now versus before it
was oh i got to pay the loan which was
exciting but at the same time it's not
hours anymore you know now it's growing
in this bank and it's just like oh my
goodness so it is really cool to see
that great job guys
very good job thank you yeah you know i
i see you too and you could see just the
smiles and and as you were sharing the
story about all the different things you
did doordash i mean you guys were doing
everything how important is it for
couples to really get on the same page
not just in the concept of the budgeting
and the baby steps but i mean getting
after it together because you both were
getting after it hard why is that so
important
well it's important i mean because you
can't do anything alone you know there's
a few months where we were doing things
differently because you know we weren't
100 connected in it yet um you know
there was times where i was putting
you know i was paying this and then we
were going out to here and it's like
well we didn't do
nothing helped there you know so at one
point we're like we need to figure this
out together um and once we did that it
just took off you know
56 000 10 months is is not something
that happens on a mistake you know you
are intentional doing it you know and we
always reminded ourselves we're doing it
now so we can live like no one else
later yeah and that is really what
motivated us to continue yeah that's a
great that's good that's very good
live like no one else so that later you
can live and give like no one else you
guys are amazing i'm so proud of you
thank you rock stars very good they're
absolute heroes they took control of
their lives how old are you
28 27 and not even 30 years old
debt-free how does it feel to be free
again
free
i love it well well done we've got a
copy of the legacy journey for you that
is the next chapter in your story for
sure you've changed your whole legacy
way to go thank you very cool and we've
got a copy of the total money makeover
for you to give away to someone and help
them start their journey and get them
moving you never know where it's going
to come from whether it's the morning
show guys talking about us or what's up
how about that that's pretty cool i'll
take it every time man thanks green bay
we appreciate you our affiliate up there
is awesome that's very cool good stuff
very very good stuff all right it's matt
and sammy green bay wisconsin
56 000 paid off in 10 months making 75
to 109 count it down let's hear a debt
free scream
three two one where's that free
[Applause]
that is
fabulous
well so well done
so well done absolutely fun
you know there's always a story about
hard work
and extra income
and the good news is right now in
america it's available everywhere
there's a shortage of workers yeah it's
unbelievable time day for people to
actually switch
people are paying more
than they would normally pay to attract
you if you're talented they're offering
increased benefits such as
signing bonuses tuition reimbursement or
in some cases full tuition
and i'm always struck by every time we
do a debt free stream i've yet to hear
one
where there wasn't an increase in income
through the journey i love that we
always look at that and that speaks to
what you're talking about the hard work
they see the prize it's so sweet to look
through the glass and see sammy's tears
because there's hard work there there's
accomplishment there's sacrifice and so
the tears are tears of joy because of
the accomplishment
it's worth it
every time when you when you leave it
all on the field and you break through
the tape on the finish line yes tears of
jewel that's worth crying i'm just
saying that's right
i cry every time i do that and to be
finished
just happy to be done yeah just so happy
to be here it's so true
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture of the day matthew 6 20
and 21 store up for yourselves treasures
in heaven
where moths
and rust do not destroy and where
thieves do not break in and steal for
where your treasure is there your heart
will be also robert louis stevenson said
don't judge each day by the harvest you
reap but by the seeds
you plant
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five you jump in we'll
talk about your life and your money
mitch is with us mitch is in phoenix hi
mitch how are you
i'm great dave
good what's up
so um
i'm a smaller general contractor i
specialize in
small to medium large
commercial construction projects and um
one of the things we've been having
trouble this last year is cash flow a
big time with you know with delays and
material and just labor shortages like
everything just cash flow and it's been
really hard to try and catch up
um we've been we've paid off a
significant amount of debt over the last
18 months even through all these issues
but still are having cash flow problems
and
one of the solutions my wife and i have
been kicking around and it's kind of
bittersweet is to sell our house um to
help out with the problems we've been
having and
we you know uh we're and so yeah okay if
you have a labor shortage
then you don't have money going out for
labor how does that create a cash flow
problem
um well we're pushing enlarged
commercial projects we can be out
anywhere from 60 to 90 days worth of
labor so yes we have a labor shortage um
you know which is causing us to not be
able to hire the amount of employees we
need to do the work so it's causing me
to go out in the field instead of doing
my job in the office if that makes sense
but that doesn't cause cash flow
problems
um
you're right it's it's putting out the
money for 60 to 90 days so but you're
not putting out the money because the
people aren't working because there's a
shortage okay well i i i misspoke and i
apologize i'm just i'm trying to
understand because that's just okay so
uh but but what is happening is
your contractors are jerking you around
more than ever
yeah
well no so we're substitute so we're
general contractors specializing in
we're sub for all intents our purposes
so we sub contract we do um
we do millworks construction and door
and hardware is what we specialize in
but we're a general contractor okay so
you go and you inside but you go and you
install
mill work and doors and then it's it's
60 to 90 days before you get paid
yep yeah so and that's the way it's
always been that's the way it's always
been and it got worse during covid
because of the banks weren't coming
these are all bank finance projects so
they're anywhere from like okay so i'm
back to my point
your contractor that brought that
brought you in to put the windows and
doors in is jerking you around because
the bank's jerking him around jerking
his client around and they're so they're
throwing you out another 30 or 45 days
beyond what your business model used to
be
yeah you know as you know they say crap
rolls downhill yeah it does and so your
problem is your house isn't gonna fix
your price that's right
that's exactly you're right and like
you're you're completely right you have
a business model that you have a
business model that's broken yeah
okay so you are going to have to quit
taking bad business
and bad business is business that does
not pay on time
okay now you have a broken business
model and so you're going to have to go
contractors who are going to jerk me
around who are not going to pay their
bill on time are not going to get my
services
because i would rather do nothing
than work for somebody and not get paid
on time and get my tail in a crack
yeah and it's gotten better dave like no
no stop it through this whole you're
getting you called me up to sell your
own home
to fix this business model problem now
you're defending it
well
i i agree i guess i guess the amount of
equity in the house was just
a
thought process
what it is your trip my problem is
you're treating the symptom not the
problem yes yes yes
and and i think you're also ignoring how
much leverage you have mitch do you not
feel you have leverage i mean they need
you to get the job done there's a reason
why you're in business because
contractors aren't doing that work am i
right
yeah and
and there really is and like and like i
said it it's not like every project's
that it's like we've come off a
significant amount i just told you
you've been dealing with bad ones yeah
and good ones you need to fire the bad
ones and your cash flow problems are
going to go away call their bluff mitch
if they need you as much as i think they
well they're 50 percent up front yeah 50
depositor i don't show up yeah because
you've not been paying on time that's
exactly right you've got more leverage i
just changed my terms with you there's
cash on delivery yeah because you don't
pay your bills
or don't don't i'd rather not take the
job take fewer jobs make better margin
with people you want to work with that
pay on time
that you know
say no
that's that's that's why i'm calling in
but i i also was trying to
you know
maybe find a way to help pay off past
debt you know from the business and be
able to have a safety net you know what
i mean to be able to take those hits
you know
i don't want you to take those hits
i want you to turn this business model
over where they take the hits not you
yeah
i listen i've got a friend that makes
that'll make a million dollars net
profit this year on a remodeling company
he does residential remodeling
if you want him to come into your house
and do remodeling do you know what you
have to do
50
up front before he sets foot on the
dadgum job
yeah
he's not he's not he's not cash flowing
his customers
needs their cash flowing their own needs
and he's simply executing the work
but he's demanding oh and by the way
he's a phenomenal contractor yeah
the work gets done and it is pristine
and he's making bank
here's the deal mitch i'm just gonna
shoot you straight uh you're in one of
the hottest real estate markets in the
country
in what is one of the most historically
high opponents real estate yeah yeah no
pun intended and you have leverage you
need to start acting like it dave's
exactly right you need to man up and
just tell these guys stop screwing
around or i'm going to hold your doors
or i'm going to hold this i'm not going
to do and you go find somebody else
who's not going to do the job that i'm
going to do this has to stop today it
has to stop yeah i got a 50 million
commercial project going right on the
hill right here right now and i'll
guarantee you if i don't okay i'm the
customer and i've got a commercial
general contractor up there doing it and
when we sit down and do pay and it's 2
million bucks if i don't write that
check you know what happens to work up
there it stops that's exactly right and
that's not because they're bad guys no
it's our deal yeah i'm they're not
they're not my bank yeah
and i'm not i'm my bank yeah and the
their job is to build stuff not be my
you're playing banker here yeah
and so you know you've just gotta you
need to cut out about 10 of your
customers and they're causing 90 of your
problems yep
and then the other
uh on about another 15 or 20 of your
customers need to be taught new tricks
yeah and you don't have to be a jerk but
you can be direct i don't know you could
be direct and go hey look this stops
it's not it's not being unkind it's just
going this is the deal that's right my
buddy is 50 up front he's not a jerk no
he's a kind he's a wonderful man he's a
craftsman
but um but you but he's not working for
you
unless you put the he's not your bank
yeah and don't tell me the banks are
flush with cash right now no no no no
they were jerking people around there
and covered oh during coding they were
not the issue
they were sitting at home with their
thumb in their ear instead of going to
work and they were not issuing checks on
these construction loans and so the
construction loans were not going out to
the owner and and the construction and
then the owner wasn't paying the general
right and the general's not paying his
subs but that's not the end he's right
crap rolls downhill and it rolls
downhill from bank of america that's
what it rolls right so uh because
there's a big load of it over there to
roll downhill
so um
but that's just you know that's the way
that that that actually was happening
now but here's the thing you've got a
general contractor that's doing a 50
million dollar project he's got some
bank he'll find the money if the door is
gone
trust me
he's got so much leverage
you're you're let's sell your house i
want you to throw your shoulders back
and strut around a little bit more
seriously oh man you you got the stuff
you're you're on the driver's seat more
than you think you are please don't sell
your house to fix those people's
problems
please don't do that
please please don't
you may want to sell it for other
reasons but don't do it for that reason
can't call me good hour ben and kelly
great hour that puts us hour of the
ramsay show in the books we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace christ jesus
[Music]
this is james childs a producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone browse by topic or even
sync clips to your friends
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
you